EARLY ON, ON THE OFFENSISI TO
RASMUS KUPARI.
KINGS POUND IT IN
HANDLED BY QUICK.
>> Darren: COUPLE OF AMERICAN
BORN P A LOT
OF SPEED LED BY JORDAN KYROU.
IT STARTED IN HIS OWN53% OF THE
ON SATURDAY.
AS KEMPER.
KOPITAR.
KINGS HAVE THEIR TOP LINE STAYI
DISCIPLINED BUT GETTING OUT BOA.
BARBASHEV TO
RIGHT ON GOAL AND A PRETTY GOOD
SHOT THERE BY THE 18 YEARHERE B
MINNESOTA NATIVE AND PLAYED BY
BOZAK OUT OF THE  BY QUICK.
OFF BALANCE.
TO THE LINE CAN'T COVER IT.
LOST AN EDGE BUT BARBASHEV FOLS
UP.
OUT HIGH, PARAYKO.
WAITING, SHOOTING ONE.
THATAT CONN SMYTHE TROPHY
WINNER JONATHAN QUICK AND OUR
QUICK PASS TO BARBASHEV.
AND THE KINGS, A SHOT TO THE
LINE.
TIP WIDE AGAIN.
AND NOW BRAYDEN SCHENN THERE,
NOT CLEARED, PLEASURE I ASKED V
KNEW NUMBE PLAYS IT McLELLAN
THIS MORNING ABOUT THE BLAST
HERE COMES JAKE WALMAN BACK.
THAT'S OFF A WALMAN ON THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE RIGHT THERE ON
THEE
LINING UP WITH DUSTIN BROWN.
BUT THERE IS A GUY THAT SIGNED .
FAULK, NICE HIS OWN ZONE.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT INSIDE, AND
THANKS FOR COMING ON
READ IT WELL.
>> Darren: HE WAS KIND OF TRYING
TO LAY THAT COUPLE INCHES OFFS
BREAK FOR THE BLUES, TARASENKO
IN THE CLEAR
CONFIDENCE.
WREAKING OF IT.
OUR COMES THEY'RE
5-0, FLORIDA IS 6-0, EDUCATE
MONEY TON 5-0.
IF THE BLUES HANG ON IT WILL BE
THE FIRST TIME IN NHL HISTORY
FOUR TEAMS HAVE STARTED 5-0 IN
THE HISTORY Y